hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2016 Daniel Dwight here
hosting a bunch of very cool demos
joined by Peter Brad and very happy to
have the creative director of
NetherRealm Studios mr. ed boon noob
saibot himself hey doing my friend I'm
very good i mean really appreciate you
having us here too no problem sorry for
a little bit of a delay we had to make
sure all the superheroes are ready yeah
injustice to yes you guys are back
coming at some stage in 2017 yeah what's
it like getting back on back on and
justice it's like a every time you
release a game you just have like a
palate cleanser and you're on on to a
new front yeah exactly you know is in
mortal kombat injustice are so different
from each other you know it's kind of
like you know it taps into different
parts of our you know creative brains
that we can put all the blood aside and
put into the go into super hero mode
with with the first and justices
inevitably characters that we couldn't
include right and and a lot of you know
really angry I'm sorry passionate
depending that they have it and so this
is a good opportunity for us to do that
you know like like the these you know
Atrocitus Gorilla Grodd yeah girl you
know these are the characters that were
kind of introducing here as well as this
big you know what we're calling the gear
system for the game is what's that
selection process like because obviously
it involves you it involves the vocal
fans and then presumably also involves
DC's yeah have you come out to get your
you're sort of full deck of card um we
usually come up with a list that's like
you know eighty percent of what we ended
up being as we write the story you know
we have these very detailed kind of
cinematic stories that yeah do you know
the writers you know need characters
that they can you know certain amount of
villains certain amount of heroes and
you know we want to be able to
accommodate that and DC also you know
joins the conversation and then of
course you know the passionate players
really let their points you know be
heard on Twitter and social media yeah
and through the mailbox and chatting
outside your house I'm sure and yeah
we're loving a look at some gameplay
right here at Grodd already going at it
asked to two of the the you know new
additions to our roster Gorilla Grodd
who's you know the villain of the flash
and the Atrocitus who was kind of like
you know a big angry bloody red lantern
kind of nice almost like the opposite of
the Green Lantern was good and you know
Atrocitus is kind of like an antihero
but he's got a lot of anger issues and
but they're so far two of our big kind
of big brawlers characters grodd's kind
of interesting in that he has these kind
of big you know gorilla eight moves but
he also has kind of telekinetic moves
like like kind of like a kimchi or in
her mac or something like that it's a
great combination of the tomb and we'll
talk about the gear system in a second
but how was the fighting developed is it
very much similar to injustice the first
one we played today the groundwork is
isn't just as I mean we were with every
game we try to do we try to add layers
for players to kind of learn and master
you know like like a lot of these you
know the fighting in tournaments you
know the hardcore guys you know we're
really into the whole eSports thing
we've been doing with the Mortal Kombat
X and in the first injustice move
between participating pretty heavy and
into the tournament scene and so we've
had a number of kind of like like lower
level stuff that you know some players
may never quite experienced but the
rival guys who really want to take these
things can really
and talk to sell a bit about the gear
system so how does this work is it just
like unlocks is it and purely aesthetic
sure it's um gear in probably the
simplest of terms I would describe gear
as costume pieces that actually power up
your care so you know when you when you
finish a fight we're going to have these
these drops we're basically and the
victory screen also rewards you with
this gear and you have the choice of you
know equipping your character with that
gear or not and so there's a a molding
so to speak of as you keep getting here
you keep you know deciding if you want
to use it and you know you want to focus
on you no offense or defense or enhance
certain moves or uncertain moves and
you'll notice see here that the the
gears being rewarded and the player has
the opportunity to use equip their
character with that gear right away or
to kind of save it in a like in revolt
or yeah exactly and and then they can
you know equip their player for certain
missions or something like that they
really want to be but their defense or
offense or enhances one mood or
something like that and that kind of
customization really results in like you
know visually and gameplay wise it's
your Grodd it's your Superman your
Batman your Aquaman and that's really
the kind of foundation of what we're
building our main gameplay yeah go for
this I've got a question who is this
rocket-powered cat that keeps flying in
he is off you know Atrocitus is a Red
Lantern you know there's a spectrum of
colors and he is actually another Red
Lantern his name is Dexter it's part of
the DC lore and they're they're kind of
they kind of work together and so we
incorporated them into the fighting each
projectile oh yeah does all these uh man
is adorable yeah and yeah and we have
taken to a good crowd here as well two
of us are cat lovers yeah
and so it's it's it's um it's awesome
people who know the the Atrocitus you
know kind of backstory and yeah we'll
really appreciate that yeah how is
secure something to play into what
you're talking about earlier with
eSports are you going to lock that stuff
out is it you know yeah well certainly
you know with with you know the the
gameplay changes are are you're going to
have a significantly more powerful
version of superman after you've been
you know yeah gearing up hearing them up
and leveling enough so we will obviously
have something to level out level things
out for things like tournaments and
whatnot because you don't want to have
you know somebody coming in with a love
of 50 a superman against a level one you
know Batman or something like that but
we certainly have plans to do like a
more level playing field version at DC
are also keeping pretty busy on their
own media front at the development of
Batman vs Superman has not affected your
development at all or like even
Supergirl like what they're doing there
has any that sort of bled into what
you're doing injustice no no I mean a
lot a lot of a lot of what we do is is
kind of you know we draw inspiration
from from the comics in the movies and
the animated shows isn't really a really
big 12 but you're pretty much the
development of our stuff is independent
of the movies know that yeah I must be
fun I guess second time around is
probably a bit more trust there as well
they've seen what you've done like
previously it was like ok these crazy
Mortal Kombat devs are going to take our
DC characters and yeah make a repeat
chest Rosa yeah oh we you know when we
were pitching the first game you know
one of the things that would always say
it's like you know we have no intention
of tearing Batman's head off anything
you know a mortal kombat like this is
this you know our studio is filled with
you
superhero fans and you know so we just
love this kind of stuff with some of the
some of the some of the moves to come up
with our drawn on inspiration of
something medecine in the animated
series or something like riot and so we
love these kind of nods to the stuff
anybody who's a fan of these characters
you're really going to see how much we
we love it we love the character too mmm
Peter I know you're a mess of MORTAL
KOMBAT found as well at eight at a ten
on gamespot we gave more Kombat X we did
yeah last year yeah and actually i'm
very curious i understand the different
series obviously but what did developing
welkom backs a convex what I'll Kombat X
and then the reception that followed how
did that inform your approach to
injustice to you at all I have to
imagine there's some sort of yeah after
every game you know we can kind of take
a step back and kind of you know ask
herself you know what resonated with
people what could we have done better
and we always kind of accumulate that
stuff and put it into it you know one of
the things that we've always wanted to
do it you know as a studio what we're
always kind of moving towards is
allowing the player to have more control
over their character and so you know
with mortal kombat actually you're like
okay we're gonna make three versions of
these characters right you get to choose
which one you like you know they have
differences in terms of style of
gameplay letting them select it now
we're kind of like taking the next step
of saying okay you know these variables
that were messing with we're going to
give you access to these variables and
let you change things around and then
that kind of inspired like the leveling
things up and so this is really like a
like a overall big picture direction
that we're going
biting me if you really feel like you
know the more customization and things
that the players feel like they're
involved in right growing of these
characters the more you know it's just a
more fun experience does the gear system
purely work within the limits of the
game or is there a micro transactions
elements to that as well no we haven't
honestly we're really just getting the
whole the whole system I've been ready
but we haven't we haven't really had any
discussions about like micro
transactions and whatnot I think you
know big picture wise we really want an
experience that it's just long lasting
we were just want somebody like when you
start playing your game you're Supergirl
is just a completely different character
than what it ends up being gameplay wise
and visually you know it's it's not a
create a character thing that we
definitely don't want to give the
impression of work you know changing
them those shape and derived and things
like that but as far as like you know
the the way you want your character to
play it is still fundamentally supergirl
but it is you know you controlling the
variables that we're exposing and you
guys have got a sort of a great little
staple of games that people are enjoying
in terms of fighting games you've got
more combat series which is come to life
in the past five years again you've got
injustice are you guys sort of locked
into those now on a biannual cycle ah
it's been that way so far yeah I don't
think we've had like this kind of a big
picture plan that that that's just how
it's kind of worked out you know I it's
interesting you know what mortal kombat
x we've had the most downloadable
characters you know right recently we
were introduced you know alien and yeah
the face and all ended up and so i
bargain exactly and and those have been
featured in like we just had the ESL
tournament last saturday you know
there's like two hundred thousand
dollars in prizes and and and i was
there and it was the first time that I
was like you know we've talked my little
combat then justices since been
introduced hmm so I was bouncing between
the two games but I think as we continue
to
support these games for a longer period
of time that may affect you know the
release of the next game just because
it's we really want the game system to
be a longer-lasting experience new
content coming is it going to be a
really large robust story mode like we
saw in welcome yes absolutely you know
every every game we really try to kind
of up the previous ones as far as I had
that whole cinematic presentation and
then it sets up the fight and then the
player anticipates with that we're
adding some really cool twists that
we're going to probably towards the end
of the year we'll be talking a little
bit more about the story mode and some
of the changes were making to it but it
is going to have that really you know
that big cinematic experience enter all
these sort of like story details there
in concocted by your team or they pulled
directly from the comics in the image
well it is it is from the this universe
that I guess we kind of you know created
you know DC it's awesome how they have
the multiverse yeah we can say okay in
our virtual rappers Superman's dictator
right down you know Superman kill Shazam
and all of these things and that is kind
of spawned this this the comic book
which has been like it's become like
this right its own thing which is really
elaborated on that lower so it's we're
going to continue in that stretch okay I
knew that that whole thing to this the
comic was like the the pre chapter first
game is a first chapter second game 2
2nd chapter it's a lot of cool stuff
touch nice you get involved in that
stuff yourself a lot more calm but
always feels like it has a lot of Ed
Boon in terms of I mean like these are
characters who you've been crafting for
you know 20 years I guess yeah yeah for
20 years is it the same for injustice as
well or yeah yeah you know I mean it's
it's the you know like i said it's it's
it's a we have a studio of 150 people
who just love superhero things and so we
all it's all big collaborative effort in
terms of the story writing the game
features you know the design what the
characters do it's it's a it's a very
involved process you know we have moral
Kombat we have fatality meetings
somebody stands up not about how and I
think they rip out his butthole
I was like I don't think that's ever
been said okay stop to that I should get
enjoy ya got loads of those you should
attend problem at all right there's a
bunch of questions coming through from
the child as well mostly about is X in
game and but also some other folks
wondering are you guys going to be using
gGPO yes yes I'm glad you brought that
up you know one one of the things that
mortal kombat x el introduced was this
this rollback system that you know
dramatically improves the the online
expression everything that we've learned
we're applying into injustice too so
it's going to have a great online
netcode how many characters were in
injustice at launch I think we started
with 24 and we added six and then we
ended with like 30 not including like
some of the guests skins right like that
presumably you're going to do something
similar for just at the very least you
know MK MK 9 injustice MPX have all
added to the previous games in terms of
DLC characters kind of long-term support
and we plan on continuing that direction
with injustice what do you think the
sweet spot is for that because obviously
like gamers are very you know reticent
when it comes to DLC and thinking I go
you know I bought this game for x-men
and it doesn't have everything I want
but I haven't seen that much of a
backlash with those games specifically
is there sort of trick to us is it about
having a decent amount of characters
that they want up front or III think
like we've never we've never had like a
character that was you know on the disk
done why we asked you you know to when
we release the game we are knee-deep in
working on the DLC right now and so you
know that in just in order to release a
game that has more more characters like
that we have to do a
we have to continue working on it it's
like a long long process after the game
is launched all right um and we have
some more gear here what type of gear
are we looking at Odessa lights crowns
yeah yeah Kryptonian crown a Superman
just like this headgear that did that he
he that actually represents one of the
looks that he has in our stories like
you know he's a little bit more of a
dictator yeah we have elements that let
you kind of craft a Superman that looks
like that you know we have a chest that
is the the red Sun Superman you can you
know and clip your guy with that and
have them look like that so you notice
that he's Superman is wearing it now and
so you know that that enhances you know
there again there you can do things like
you know have a little bit more damage
with the environment or a little bit
more blocking damage or enhance a
certain special new you can unlock a
special move it's really you know like i
said it's really gets customized awesome
thank you so much for coming on and
really appreciate you taking time to
join us here on the gamespot stage and
when will we be playing injustice to you
will definitely be playing in 2017 okay
we'll probably narrow it down in there a
few months sometime next year yeah
wonderful alright thank you so much
going on thanks for having us preciate
your time yeah yeah thank you very much
for watching we have loads more games
coming up over the next couple of hours
watch dogs to Tekken 7 dead rising for
we're also getting the legends of Zelda
up here tekken 7 as well that's coming
out next year too it's just the two of
you though yeah but stick around with
back in a couple of minutes per call of
duty infinite warfare stay there
cool yeah sorry